[Music]
hey everybody send a raven they've
started announcing who the season 8 cast
members they're going to be bringing on
our so this will be a breakdown of that
just careful for spoilers for everything
through season 7 just because what to
talk about a little bit of golden
company stuff I think one of the roles
that they're casting is for that
storyline possibly to but there are
seven new cast members they've announced
per the Watchers on the wall people they
were able to get their hands on the
first casting notices so these aren't
big secrets or anything like that but
it's always a surprise that they are
able to bring in so many new people each
season and that doesn't include the
multitudes of red shirts that they have
for big crowd shots like when they have
gray worms standing here at the end of
season seven there's obviously a whole
bunch of Dothraki that ride in you have
the unsullied but there are a lot of
background actors that don't have names
so they just bring on for that day there
is a new round of the giveaway for that
new book that George R Martin released
about Aegon Suns all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so all of these
seven characters is part of this new
season eight cast are actually people
that will have on-screen roles and will
possibly interact with the main
characters a really good comparison
would be a Lascar start during the
beginning of season seven like we didn't
really see her after those first couple
of episodes but she did have important
scenes so as you can imagine from that
intro
most of these are northern characters
there are a couple that will be shooting
in Spain so that means King's Landing so
that's where we get to golden company
stuff but I'll start with the Winterfell
people so first up is a northern farmer
somewhere in his mid-20s mid-30s he's
supposed to be a straightforward honest
man of simple taste who works with the
land it is part of these casting notices
it does say when they're filming but for
the most part it's between November and
December so it's all relatively close to
the same period but I'll go through all
the names first then I'll talk about
what they actually might be doing with
these characters the next one is just
called sassy and attractive girl which I
think sounds hilarious totally sounds
like a northern person maybe somebody
from Bear Island but she's meant to be a
little bit younger like late teens early
20s the character is said to be sexy and
confident northern girl playing a good
memorable one scene part in one episode
playing opposite
leading cast so then there's a northern
century also about the same age a little
bit younger than looking for a northern
actor with great timing to play a small
part office at the leading cast so that
sounds like the gate guards that aria
ran into so sometimes they cast people
just to stand there and nod and say
lines sometimes they actually have to
have like really awesome performances so
that's why they're looking for extra
good actors even though some of these
roles are relatively minor moving south
they're looking for a sailor character
which pretty much reads Ironborn a
little bit older somewhere below the age
of fifty he's supposed to be
rough-and-ready seafaring type with a
weathered face and strong presence then
they're looking for a guard who's
supposed to be in his 20s just
physically fit able to handle himself in
a fight just has to look kind of like a
badass
they don't really specify what his skin
color is supposed to be or what
ethnicity so it's hard to place him he
could show up anywhere could be up at
Winterfell
or it could be south at King's Landing
but then they get a little bit more
specific there's just somebody listed
his guard number two who's supposed to
be a little bit older in his 30s they're
looking for someone that's tall athletic
with a military feel supposed to be
professional clear-thinking guard who is
dependable he's going to be in multiple
scenes it will shoot in Spain and he'll
be with the leading cast so just to
explain what they're doing with each of
those characters like the character that
shows up in Spain that last guard that I
mentioned that's probably in King's
Landing that's where they shoot most of
their King's Landing scenes they shoot
in Ireland for all their Winterfell
scenes with a few exceptions sometimes
they'll go up to Iceland for like the
really big scenes north of the wall but
they've changed that a little bit
remember they built out that giant
quarry as the lake set for Episode six
that was meant to double for a lot of
their Iceland scenes when they would go
north of the wall but like the reason I
included that Winterfell shot is because
that's where they're going so most of
like all this big stuff at the beginning
of the season will take place in and
around Belfast but just going down the
list the northern farmer the sassy
attractive girl are just meant to sort
of build out give more character to the
people of the north to make it feel more
real you've really only spent time at
Winterfell
but like remember back during season six
we did get a bit of a tour of the north
so it did humanize it a little bit but
not in the way that you would want
because other than the little
bear we really only met Lord Glover and
he was really unsympathetic to their
cause
so they actually really want to make you
care about it like if Lord Glover were
torn to shreds you probably wouldn't
shed any tears but then you have
characters like Ross who you get to know
during season one and even though she's
a relatively salacious character they
just want to help put a face on the
northern people that John snow is so
desperate to protect so like the
northern farmer character is meant to be
more salt of the land like I'm just
trying to make my way in the world the
sassy attractive girl sounds like more
of a comedy scene so maybe something
with tyrion maybe he tries to hit on
somebody or something with Jamie just
some awkward comedy where she isn't
having any of their [ __ ] but like I
said the northern century just sounds
like it's meant to be a really memorable
character like the Aria gate guards
maybe not quite so comedic like that was
actually a pretty brilliant scene the
way they played it even though you
probably don't remember their names you
just remember the really funny gate
guards the Sailor character is very
obviously going to be iron boar remember
Euron is going to get the golden company
so because they're filming with that
character a little bit later in December
it sounds like that will actually be a
golden company scene with them either on
one of the ships or them arriving at
King's Landing we already talked about
that second guard even though they only
specify the second guard is supposed to
be in Spain the first guard might be
hand-in-hand with that like you have a
younger character with a slightly older
guard character so they're probably
something tied to Cersei in like I've
said before they start shooting in the
middle of October and most of these new
characters don't start shooting till the
middle of November so just turning the
timeline it sounds like that first month
of shooting that they have will be
mostly main characters doing a lot of
the reunion moments at Winterfell like
Jon Snow Daenerys arriving may be Gendry
arrives Jaime probably arrives bran
shouldn't be too far behind him you have
the Hound so you get through all the
really cool stuff first and then you
start exploring the stuff that's going
in and around Winterfell which is where
you get the background characters there
isn't much of an indication about what's
gonna be happening with Cersei in the
first couple of episodes because it
sounds like it's gonna take a little
while for the golden company to arrive
but they could be filming a lot of that
separately because it's meant to be such
a big thing it'll require some special
effects especially for all those
ship-based scenes with
Huron for the most part it sounds like
she's going to be spending most of her
time at least early on in that map room
just talking about the things that she's
done so far since the end of last season
assuming there's a bit of a time gap
just trying to win over the rest of the
southern lures that are on the fence
that aren't sure whether or not they
want to support Jon Snow and Daenerys
because of everything that's happened
think of it as another version of this
scene here where she was trying to paint
Daenerys is this really terrible
Conqueror only she adds White Walkers
into that pile - but house Tyrell is an
open rebellion against the crown with
their help the mad Kings daughter has
ferried an army of savages to our shores
mindless unsullied soldiers who will
destroy your castles in your holdfasts
Dothraki heathens who will burn your
villages to the ground but let me know
in the comments which other new
characters do you want them to include
during season aid now these aren't the
only characters that they're casting
these are just people that will be
shooting before the end of the year
remember they're gonna be shooting all
the way up to the summer of next year so
there's all of next year for more
characters like this so if we do get any
more casting updates I'll do new videos
but my next game of Thrones video will
be a breakdown of that new Aegon
Targaryen story it's about his children
really so I'll try to get that out in
the next couple of days but
congratulations - you only live once
you're the latest giveaway winner you
win a copy of that new book please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details you can click here for more
Rhaegar and Lyanna and you can click
here to rewatch Maisie Williams new
Marvel movie that she's in she actually
turns into a wolf the wolf turns into a
wolf in the Marvel Universe thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you